when you were in the Jeff Beck Group of
course you are the lead singer Jeff Beck
great guitar player right who is better
Ron Wood or Jeff Beck as a guitar player
can't compare the two Ronnie's got an
innate sense of Rhythm right and riff
writing whereas Jeff he's just the
sounds he gets out of his guitar he's an
entrepreneur of the guitar so when you
were with uh the Jeff Beck Group going
back in the day and you're and you're
working together The Story Goes that you
guys were booked to play Woodstock am I
correct yep and you're about to do
Woodstock and Jeff Beck they say got
called back because someone had said to
him your wife is cheating on you and it
turned out the story was [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] the garden that was shagging
his wife yeah
is he gonna do were you pissed when you
saw the result of Woodstock and the
movie and all that because for a career
it's a huge boost right it would have
been great for you to be a Woodstock
career-wise yeah I don't know whether it
would have been good or whether we'd
have been labored would start act for
the rest of our lives right but it's
hard to say the rumor was that Jeff Beck
was really a prick to work with it was
he difficult did you say that yes but
you say it repeat what I said let me let
me put it this way he he wasn't a good
band leader right you know he didn't
have the personal touch with the
musicians you know Ronnie and I used to
sometimes have to go and steal eggs here
in New York to to survive really we
weren't given any money and that wasn't
his fault it was Peter Grant you know he
was managed Zeppelin at the time right
and we'd have we'd have no money because
we didn't have new wages so think
yourself lucky you lot that's right look
at all the money stealing Rod Stewart uh
it doesn't make you go uh steel eggs but
but speaking of that Peter Grant was the
manager of Led Zeppelin you've said that
your band with Jeff Beck that Zeppelin
really got most of their ideas from that
man right yeah and and Woody and Jeff
would say the same things when we were
we were formed and playing gigs and you
know one time uh yeah uh Jimmy Page came
and saw us with uh with plant and then
John Bonham and Jimmy Page and plan and
then Percy Robert Plant all came they
all came to see us and then they did a
couple of songs that we did do you get
like hey wait a second they're kind of
taking our sound and they're taking the
songs that we do and uh style it was
your start do you get upset in a way
when they start to have success you
don't you don't get lost too short it
really is yeah have you ever talked to
Jimmy Page bastards if you were a young
man then you didn't have that
perspective no but Robert Plant and
Jimmy Page Jefferson don't say boys uh
these are songs we open with these are
songs we do because you [ __ ] calm
down maybe we should have but Robert's a
good mate of mine I love him dearly
thank you